We've done several videos now
on amines, which I forgot to
mention, and this is probably
the most fun notion about
amines, is that they
tend to be smelly.
Let me write this down.
Amines tend to be smelly.
And I can make the smelly
smell a little bit.
And in general, in their gaseous
state, they'll often
smell like ammonia, so it's a
very strong smell, or in their
liquid state, they usually
smell like fish,
or even dead fish.
They smell like fish.
And, in particular, if you look
at trimethylamine, so
this is-- let me draw
it like this.
H3C, you have your nitrogen.
You have CH3 and then
you have your CH3.
And you can even draw
the lone pair.
This is trimethylamine.
This is the fish smell.
This right here is
the fish smell.
Now, the whole reason why I
brought this up is because in
this video, we're going to
introduce a new type of
molecule, and that's
an aldehyde.
And I want to contrast
their smells.
Now, some of the smaller
aldehydes still have a pretty
strong smell, in particular,
formaldehyde.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about
why this is an aldehyde.
So this right here is
formaldehyde, and that's the
common name.
And you've probably seen
it used as a kind of
preservative.
Maybe even in your biology
class, if there's like a dead
frog in a solution, it's
probably inside of
formaldehyde.
Let me write this down.
Formaldehyde.
Once again, this is
the common name.
I'm going to teach you in a
second how to systematically
name these things.
But when you have larger
aldehydes, they actually can
have a pretty sweet or
even a rosy smell.
So you have something like
benzaldehyde, which you
actually saw when we started
the benzene derivatives.
So this is benzaldehyde
right over here.
Let me write this down.
This is benzaldehyde.
And then this molecule here,
just when I tell you what it's
called, you'll probably guess
what it smells like.
So this has a benzene
ring like this.
And then you have one,
two, three carbons.
The last one's double bonded
to an oxygen and then a
hydrogen like there, and
they have a double
bond right over here.
And this is called
cinnamaldehyde.
And as you could guess, this
smells like cinnamon.
And, in fact, this is the
molecule in cinnamon that
gives it its smell, although you
don't want to have large
quantities of it or it
might be poisonous.
But in cinnamon, it's a
very pleasant thing.
So larger aldehydes tend to
have kind of a nice, rosy,
sweet, flowery smell.
The smaller ones tend to
be kind of pungent.
If you open up that jar in your
biology class and smell
that frog, it will not
be a pleasant smell.
So now that I've talked about
smell enough, I think, let's
talk about what makes an
aldehyde an aldehyde.
And you might even see
a pattern here.
In all of these aldehydes that
I've drawn, we have a carbon
double bonded to an oxygen.
And actually, this part of it
right here, and we'll see this
over and over again, this is
called a carbonyl group.
So that is a carbonyl group.
This right here is
a carbonyl group.
And you even see it over here.
But that by itself is
not the distinctive
feature of an aldehyde.
You'll see that in other
types of molecules.
Let me write it here.
Carbonyl.
What's distinctive about an
aldehyde is, attached to the
carbon in the carbonyl,
you have a hydrogen.
And sorry, I forgot to draw
this hydrogen here on
benzaldehyde.
You have a hydrogen here.
So, in general, an aldehyde
is something
that looks like this.
You have a carbonyl group.
You a carbonyl group.
You have a hydrogen, and then
you just have some other type
of carbon chain.
This right here is the simplest
possible aldehyde,
and actually, this chain
ends up being
just another hydrogen.
Now, these three that I've shown
right here, these are
their common names, and these
are the way that most people
will talk about formaldehyde,
benzaldehyde, or
cinnamaldehyde, so they're just
kind of good to know.
And I'll show you one more.
And this is a pretty
important one.
Let me do it down here so
we have some space.
So another one looks like this,
so bonded to a CH3 over
here and then a hydrogen.
This right here is called
acetaldehyde.
And I just wanted to expose
you to these common names
because this is what
people normally
use for these molecules.
Now, there is an IAPUC-- I
always forget the acronym.
There is a systematic
way to name them.
It's actually pretty
straightforward.
You just look at the longest
carbon chain, and you always
start numbering at the carbon
that's in the carbonyl group.
And it's always going to be at
the end of the chain because
that's always going to be
bonded to a hydrogen.
Actually, let me just
make clear that
this is also an aldehyde.
You have your carbonyl group,
and on one end, you have a
hydrogen, just like that.
Now, the systematic way of it,
you just look at the longest
carbon chain.
Over here, there's
just one carbon.
So here, you would call this,
the systematic name, you would
call this methanal,
not methanol.
Methanol would mean you would
have an OH group.
But since you have this double
bond and you have a hydrogen,
or you could say this double
bond is at the end of the
carbon chain, this
is an aldehyde.
So the systematic name is
methanal, not methanol.
Let me make that clear.
This is methanal right there.
This one, I won't do
cinnamaldehyde or
benzaldehyde, because this is
really the only way that
people name them.
Actually, frankly, formaldehyde,
people never
call it methanal.
And acetaldehyde, they'll never
call it what I'm about
to name it, but the systematic
name is, the longest carbon
chain, you have one, two
carbons, so it is ethanal.
Ethanal, I don't want to
pronounce it incorrectly.
So let's do a couple more of
these, just to make sure we
have a decent understanding of
the systematic names here.
And in general, if you have
a really long chain, the
systematic names are
what is used.
So this thing right here,
what would you call it?
It's clearly an aldehyde.
You have a carbonyl group, a
hydrogen, and you have one,
two, three carbons.
So three carbons, the prefix
is prop-, so it's propanal.
It's an aldehyde.
If we want to do something
slightly more complicated,
let's do something like this.
What would this be called?
Let's see, we have one, two,
three, four, five.
We have five carbons.
So it will be pent-.
Penta-, and then it's
obviously an
aldehyde, so it's pentanal.
And you always assume that you
start numbering at the carbon
in the carbonyl group, so one,
two, three, four, five.
And on the two carbon, you
have a methyl group.
So this is 2-methyl.
So you have a methyl
group right here.
So this is going to be
2-methylpentanal.